Gisele Bundchen and Tom Brady have
called it quits
I think he just
as time as we can together and you know
it's a busy life we have don't let that
retirement fool you with her she stirs
you worse more than any retired person I
know on Friday the two announced the
news on Instagram Giselle writing that
they have amicably finalized their
divorce quote the decision to end a
marriage is never easy but we have grown
apart and while it is of course
difficult to go through something like
this I feel blessed for the time we had
together and only wish the best for Tom
always the two tied the knot in 2009 and
our parents to 12 year old Benjamin and
nine-year-old Vivian Tom is also dad to
15 year old Jack from his previous
relationship with Bridget Moynihan I
don't get all the opportunities in the
during the season to spend with the
children and with my wife so
that's that's what off season's such a
nice time for me
Giselle writes that they will continue
co-parenting to give them the love care
and attention they greatly deserve
they're just special moments with your
family and you know it's a um you know
it's a great part of my life and you
know I take advantage of it when I can
meanwhile Tom shared a similar sentiment
writing that their children will
continue to be the center of their world
Azores tells ET Giselle and Tom worked
on the terms of their settlement with a
mediator it has all been worked out and
they agreed to joint custody of their
children and Tom writes that the
decision to end their marriage has been
painful and difficult quote we wish only
the best for each other as we pursue
whatever new chapters in our lives that
are yet to be written
news of their split comes after Gisele
was spotted without her wedding ring and
was noticeably absent from Tom's games a
source previously told ET that the two
haven't been in a good place the source
added that Giselle feels like Tom has
chosen his career over his family and
she is tired of it quote she also has
her own dreams and aspirations and
doesn't want to have to keep putting her
goals on hold I feel like I'm so driven
to succeed in football and that's taken
me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife and she's really held it
down for our family yeah and I'm just
super grateful that you know she really
committed so much of her time the last
you know 14 years to make sure
everything was so stable at home so I
could go live my dreams of course this
all comes after Tom's decision to
unretire from the NFL back in March a
source previously told E.T that Giselle
had been telling Tom for a while that he
needed to spend more time with the
family and after he retired she thought
she was getting what she asked for quote
once Tom decided to go back to the NFL
she was devastated Giselle is very hurt
meanwhile A source told E.T earlier this
month Tom was holding out hope that they
could work things out quote he loves his
family but also wants to continue his
career he feels like he is in a tough
spot
foreign